i was never a gang member right
only adjacent right
okay
you're down i'll tell you that much
start the timer so far so good remember
if you can swallow it
right
yeah get some saliva do you taste it at
all the flavor i don't remember if there
was a flavor to it it's just spicy nasty
to me that ship was bought the same time
the ones we ate
[Music]
hey yo
you at the [ __ ] corey phelps show
last night what was that about dying
at your comment or your post where he
says he owes me and twenty years
[Laughter]
it has to be a weird experience uh
it was a it was a wild night it was a
wild night and uh
though the entire story we're gonna put
together and like why i even went uh on
like a youtube kind of vlog yeah
but uh so you want to get yeah you don't
have to get too much away but
synopsis
he had what he called his love left 2.1
6 cd box set that he was releasing for
350 dollars
six cd box set he has that many songs
evidently
also quick question before all this were
you originally a corey fan part of the
fell fam yes were you a part of
[Laughter]
i really liked his uh his his movies and
stuff back in the day i mean they're all
cory's yeah but it was my buddy pat who
i do another podcast with uh and he
he just like discovered twitter and then
he started following corey feldman and
then he saw this info about corey and we
just kind of dove in
but he released the six cd box up for
350 two weeks later he dropped it to 222
dollars
and i asked i just was like hey why
would you punish your fans that went out
and bought it right away yeah and i
basically said that i bought it and i
wanted 128 dollars and that was the
whole idea that was i thought it was i
thought he was charging that for tickets
yeah
he did charge 122 for the meet and greet
which brian and i uh y'all actually did
it yeah
you could pull the mic over how like
what like
it was wild doctor dr dre's son came out
on that one story that put it where a
rapper came out on stage it was dr dre's
son
um
dude you know what cory's been doing
that [ __ ] these weird [ __ ]
videos and [ __ ] since like the [ __ ]
80s
oh yeah there's like he's been like
there's this michael jack like he has
this like weird alter
ego of like a michael jackson dress [ __ ]
yeah and dance was like him yeah
but i mean was he does he sound good
i mean
yeah i don't know he was a good
performer like the energy was was
awesome yeah was it it was a whiskey a
go-go okay okay it was a tuesday night
the crowd is pretty into it this is
narcissism but i feel like my faux
energy up front and stage like really
yo did did he sell out
uh he's he's
there's a crowd there was a crowd
there's no way he [ __ ] sold out did
anyone know that was dr jerry's son yeah
i didn't even know i didn't no i didn't
know until this morning
they just introduced him or like he came
on stage during the song and there was
no sort of explanation of who he was i
think did he say he said something like
i think his name is curtis
he said kurt he might have said curtis
uh but no one knows but i don't know dr
dre's son as curtis huh so it's a little
like a little vague yeah yeah she said
also
what is he on songs with corey [ __ ]
filming that that one i mean the
comeback king remix
got
it's a banger actually bro you know so
funny about you is like when you get
into something you [ __ ]
get into it and like you [ __ ] go
you're the biggest troll i know like
yeah you go deep i like i want to do
more [ __ ] like that yesterday because
like just knowing the camera was on me
like i was just out in the dance floor
and [ __ ] and i was just like i was in
character it was awesome it's funny
because like i don't know like
you you don't go out much not anymore
really yeah because i feel like you're
just kind of like busy with all this
[ __ ] and so like to see you i was like
when you see your [ __ ] teacher out
and [ __ ]
you're like whoa and that's what you
chose to do in your free time which is
hilarious it's more work
but but uh i'm excited for the final
product uh
it's gonna be good yeah his home his
homie [ __ ] passed
he he still every every show he does a
tribute and that's sweet so the show was
on two two two
uh uh
he wanted it that way yeah cause like
corey i can't remember exactly but his
favorite number is two the other corey's
favorite number is 22
and um yeah he's just been riding uh
cory the other quarry i mean honoring
cory's coattail or
he's been honoring
uh
corey it was just hard it's hard for me
to like listen to the to those kind of
interviews like especially like uh like
the nick carter no not nick carter um
aaron carter aaron carter oh it's hard
for me to listen to those interviews
because i feel like sometimes i'm not
saying stevo was doing this but i'm
saying like a lot of times i feel like
people just [ __ ]
try to like
get the goofy [ __ ] out of them or like
interview them in ways where it's like
not genuine so it's [ __ ] hard to
listen to we know what i mean we had
like the same thought like
and so
he's a huge chat do you know all guests
no breaks channel five news
that's like i'm just so into his [ __ ]
but he has the ability to like he like
he interviewed check chet hanks he goes
to like white rap festivals but he has
ability to just like he's just
participating he's not like poking fun
and that's like the mindset we were
trying to do like i wasn't like making
fun of him at all we talked to him do
you work with that dude yeah all guys no
no no
no
he he's seen all everything he's done
i've recently just like dove in i just
love love his [ __ ] yeah but uh
um
this is editor my bro uh brian my editor
from wisconsin and shout out to lacrosse
massive channel five fan the first night
we're here there's a mechanic shop like
a block away for me the channel five
news van was there it was like a sign to
us like
seriously
so you just start yeah you're taking on
you're taking on new [ __ ] heights but
i am nick but but we were we were nice
to corey and like it didn't get like it
actually had a nice wrap up and he
immediately was like i'm sorry i'll do a
free cameo uh you should have seen you
should have seen that anybody who bought
it before the price discount i didn't
add i kind of forgot kind of pushed out
that i didn't see that because he
blocked me on twitter but
he doesn't know because you called him
out yeah but i think i was the reason
all those people got cameo when i say
all those people maybe four people
that was good though distraction uh top
of the show uh i didn't forget we got to
take our
magic box magic mine was about to go
more into it what the [ __ ]
everybody's saying are you taking it
what's your name brian yeah i haven't
had one yet you're taking it i'll take
it i mean we you get to take it i'll
take it [ __ ]
okay you gonna do it
oh yeah i'm to do it oh damn
don't be a little [ __ ] right now who's
this theo once said during the one chip
challenge you're all taking it or
everybody's fired oh yeah that was the
funniest thing
it was all right
who's that is that guys
oh yeah so this is actually james
bashera the ceo of magic mind he saw the
show and he loved our read and he has
about he loved it let's hear it thanks
okay i was saying
it's after dark crew
this is james the founder and creator of
magic mind ecstatic to be partnering
with you all yeah on the new podcast
loving the new podcast so far meatball
is also my favorite like chappelle's dad
oh yeah and she held a note for you hell
yeah i almost got that this is a
thousand times you will probably see the
same arc that i've seen over the last
nine years of of creating magic mind is
that you start with skepticism
you hear a claim like the best morning
ritual drink in the world and you're
like ah how can it be that great and
then by day three you're not just a
believer but you are a die-hard fan i
have a feeling that will happen for you
and
the rest of the cats after dark crew and
if it doesn't happen for you mom's the
word because i am a sponsor so you zip
it
don't tell them i think you're going
through each other
if it's not positive okay
i hate to get corporate but i will don
a suit tie
throw things around yell obscenities
come get in your face
if you get in the way of our ambitions
as a company okay
anyhow
and if anyone doesn't dig magic mine
tweet at us and i will personally
provide a refund it is something that uh
yeah we guarantee it and we're so proud
of what we've built that you literally
can just tweet that you had a negative
experience boom and you get a refund
thanks for partnering with us and we're
looking forward to the rest of the park
yeah he's closer cheers
i respect that uh retweeting your
negative [ __ ] i guess to extend i hate
the [ __ ] you know
all that [ __ ] cheers cheers come on now
good job yeah
but yeah so
i met james he's actually he's a huge
theo fan then he uh he's been doing
audio pockets for a while called below
the line he
he was a silicon valley guy he had like
a company that he founded that was like
venmo before venmo called tilt and then
he sold it called what tilt till but
then uh ben will kind of started to
overtake it so he sold it to airbnb and
now this is like his next venture and
they've just passed they sold a million
bottles of magic mine oh yeah
[Laughter]
the third month we'll have just like a
montage of us doing that yeah it'll be
audio of chappelle just like taking it
back to back i love it i love you are
you feeling it i'm starting to feel it i
mean i might ask for a refund but i'm
just kidding
i'll refill refill
[Music]
and if you want to feel like me
do magic mine yeah you know so what's up
with you guys
[ __ ] mother [ __ ] yeah
yeah i go to kansas city uh
this weekend oh no no i'll be in kansas
city this hard to be out
oh yeah
right because i was under yeah i'll be
getting back from kansas city do you do
do you do stuff
during the day during the day what do
you mean like walk around yeah yeah yeah
or you're trying to get over yeah yeah
because i'm i can't i'm not like i'm not
a homebody like that like i am a
homebody but to an extent to where like
i do like to like
do
random [ __ ] like hikes and [ __ ]
check out the city like i [ __ ] with food
and [ __ ] like that a lot of vegans
i [ __ ] with a lot of vegan food and
someone sent me like a bunch of vegan
food restaurants and all that [ __ ] so
that's like pretty dope but other than
that like yeah yeah i can't [ __ ] do
the
like just like there's weirdo comedians
that just stay in their [ __ ] hotels
until the [ __ ] show time and it's
like that's so [ __ ] weird like i
would go i would go crazy yeah and i
honestly i don't like staying in hotels
i [ __ ] hate it really yeah i love a
good hotel i [ __ ] hate it do you get
night
i hate it when i'm doing uh comedy [ __ ]
going on the road for comedy do they pay
for it or do you pick out your own hotel
yeah
but but i i got an airbnb i'm like i'm
not doing a hotel yeah because when you
go do you get a nice hotel or is it yeah
i love a nice hotel right i love a nice
hotel i guess they usually have a really
big bathtub a roller coaster
slippers yeah yeah i just feel like it's
such a [ __ ] i feel like i'm in a dorm
room a really nice normal beard that's
how i feel in a [ __ ] hotel room maybe
that's why i like it i've i always
wanted to have the dorm experience in
college no i went to community college
for two years to save money plus i did
terribly in high school i had to go to
dorms
when you're a freshman uh no uh when
you're a freshman i believe so i
transferred in when i was technically a
incoming junior and they didn't have any
dorms available first uh yeah i went to
a community college for the first two
years and then i transferred out to usc
and they didn't have any more dorms yeah
available for people who are
transferring yeah the dorm life i mean i
only did it when i was in we had dorms
in junior college that was because it
was in like a small town yeah and it's
like where else are you gonna [ __ ]
live did you dorm with other students or
specifically like students in the
cheerleading now the cheerleaders we had
our own [ __ ] side okay got it that we
had or whatever and there was like no
yeah it wasn't co-ed there's no girls
around her or loud or whatever blah blah
blah
but i had a homie
man this dude i cheered with man he was
getting with all these like [ __ ]
athletes
he was like straight like straight up
just like you see him coming out of his
room in the morning yeah and he's like
he was like super flamboyant so gay
obviously yeah yeah
what will the audience know
it's not the athletes
i had a friend in the theater department
same exact thing very flamboyant gay man
and was just hooking up with football
players at usc on the low yeah that's
what i'm saying they'd be they'd be
doing [ __ ] like this yeah because all of
all the football players and basketball
players whoever he was getting with they
would all look at him like they he they
they would give him so much attention
yeah it was [ __ ] insane they would
give this dude so much attention it was
almost like they're they're like
magnetic yes he loved
the attention he loved the [ __ ]
attention and when he got that attention
he would like flirt with him and they'd
be like no no no no no no no
the next thing you
in the morning before class and i just
see the dude walking out of homeboy's
room right it's just [ __ ] so awesome
dude it was so [ __ ] it was crazy it's
so funny how to get down though and it's
such like a specific type of athlete too
it's always the athlete that's like no
no
it's the one who always like
talks [ __ ] about gay people or like are
super homophobic always them like late
at night very aggressive saturday they
got done partying they don't really have
anything else to do that night they
always end up at my family yeah because
it was either that those guys or the
guys that would give them like attention
or there was guys that like just
genuinely
liked him and thought he was cool or
whatever that weren't trying to do
anything but it was once that like gave
him attention and would like poke at him
to get him like started because he was
so he's a funny [ __ ] dude yeah and
just like hair is mad they're the
biggest queen in the [ __ ] world
and i mean k-w-e-e-n
that's how they spell it right but uh
uh
no they do kw okay got it like the gay
dudes do kw really you know what i'm
saying yeah yeah yes queen yeah yeah
yeah yeah
nick nick yeah
he understands the culture nick knows a
lot about him
what'd you say i said a little too much
what's wrong with that meatball nothing
are you are you not being pc right now
meatball am i ever
no you're not you [ __ ] rhode island
kids i swear to god respect to that true
to yourself but yeah i mean i mean i was
like when i think about i was like man i
was around so many gay dudes like there
was a one point time you're in the
cheerleading i don't know i don't know i
don't know but i just because i don't
think of it like that until like
where i'm at in my life
where i'm at like now like
this is my everyday [ __ ] you know what i
mean so you know being around gay like
at one point in time majority of my
friends were girls and gays mm-hmm that
was it that's interesting i felt the
same way going to
um college at usc for the first time
where i had never seen so many white
people in my life that it like it was
such a weird
sort of like
moment when i got on campus and i saw a
bunch of people that look like nick and
meatball and i thought it was such a
cool experience i felt like i was going
to school abroad yeah because in san
jose it was mainly asians and mexicans
and then there would be like black
people and middle eastern people kind of
like sprinkled in and some white people
but most of white people i grew up
around were like teachers really the
white people were teachers and so
there'd maybe be like five other white
kids but they were like jewish so it
didn't really count in my head and going
to usc i'm like whoa there's so many
white people here it's so [ __ ] cool i
thought i was in england yo real talk i
didn't know any jewish people in time
moved to [ __ ] los angeles really yeah
i didn't know we i didn't i mean i'm not
so sure that we if we did they weren't
very vocal about it or anything like
that but i didn't really know any jewish
they were undercover jews yeah yes yes
they were hiding in addicts they got
gays in lacrosse
oh yeah oh yeah
i uh
i experienced racism the other day
what wait uh so uh it was actually
was it to you or to someone else all
right what what area are we in uh
koreatown okay
and uh it was actually it was last
thursday when we were here brian and i
were here
dumping footage
got home at like 10 and then i was like
let's go get korean barbecue because i'm
trying to show him as much as la [ __ ]
the best we went to quarters which said
it was over until midnight yeah let's go
it's 10 51.
uh p.m
and uh the first hostess i was like for
two and he's like
and he didn't really say anything he
just walked away and then uh or the host
it was a dude and then the hostess came
up and she's like oh i'm sorry we closed
the kitchen and i know if i would have
been a korean man i would have been
allowed to eat
close the kitchen at 10 51. yeah that's
pretty early
and it was kind of popping in there
still like yeah i'm telling you so then
we had to [ __ ] go to tobang
and which is also a great place but it's
not korean barbecue yeah they don't cook
they don't cook it in front of you it's
like it lessens the experience it's more
so like uh drinking food yeah it is like
the spot right you'll say quarters
quarters and pounds is the spot for
people who want really good korean
barbecue and kind of drink i think king
hodong is much better if you're just
talking about straight korean barbecue
where did we go and so uh we went to
quarters yeah wasn't going to quarters
but it's not nowhere near quarters or
kangaroo
yeah but dude i get uh
racism from koreans
i can't speak korean i can't speak queen
right so before i would go clubbing
korean clubbing do you know i talked
about korean club before it's where you
tell us about it you have to know
someone yeah at the club you have to
know one of the the waiters who's also
your host who handles everything you
have to know someone and then everyone
has to have a look you have to be just a
look
sometimes you have to be good looking
sometimes you have something you have
whatever good looking but you gotta you
gotta be of some type of caliber some
type of status yes but you gotta be able
to you should be there yeah right now
even back down i thought i was like yeah
i'm all right but then i can't speak
korean well and they picked up on that
real quick
so so they deny people at the door all
the time they're like no sorry i
wouldn't have enough room but then
you'll see the next group of people come
in talk korean and they'll let them in
do you so you have to chat with them
could you just be the strong silent type
they always talk to you they will always
talk to you in the front yeah yeah hey
chen nick get that racism hell yeah so
don't worry about their races against me
too uh
i'm not hey but like
that was like that's basically you
experienced the scene from remembering
the titans uh yeah that scene yeah
where where sunshine tried to walk uh
homeboy and then he's like hey man we
probably don't know
yeah that's that was that was you i
[ __ ] remember the titans oh that's my
[ __ ] film yeah i love that goddamn
film but that's what you experienced how
did you feel uh it didn't make you feel
interesting i was just more disappointed
he was even like uh this guy came all
the way from wisconsin uh which then
they were like no you definitely can't
come in
i will say the uh workers at quarters
are always unfriendly i don't know what
it is it's just yeah
always unfriendly i thought koreans love
white people no they love anyone they
love
they love people that's going to bring
them business no matter what right but i
don't know so the korean barbecue thing
doesn't make sense to me as far as being
racist but
did you have a certain look did you have
a hood yeah maybe you looked a little
intimidating yeah you had a hood on like
you didn't have money or something
yeah we essentially got cut off from
food really
we were like waiting for like more uh
the other dishes not because we still
had like plenty in front of us yeah but
like i was like is i was almost gonna
tell her just to put it to in a to-go
thing and i was like oh we we have two
more dishes coming she's like
she was like isn't this good like like
we we ordered just so much not knowing
how giant the portions were we got like
we got like six different numbers and it
was it was a lot of [ __ ] food and a
lot of money too right it was like 160
bucks damn that dude that's expensive
wait 160 bucks between two people or
yeah two people that's great we got
about so yeah
like four or four dishes i don't know i
maybe i got rid of that kind of makes
sense huh what sexy yeah how much you
don't spend money ever huh wait do you
think they're over charging him because
he's white no no yeah they had the
prices
that's awesome they spent 160 bucks
worth of food or yeah with the food yeah
that quarters that could have been yours
i know that's your 160 because quarters
they have like seven menus too so you
can get like a combo and it's somewhere
like 79 or whatever so if you bought one
soju almost the same price yeah you know
what's weird about it now i'm thinking i
keep thinking about the racism stuff
when i think about it for myself
personally i think i've laughed at you
every time someone's trying to be racist
towards me
i think it was just like it's a great
attitude yeah it's a great good attitude
it's a positive
though why is that because it just i
mean it's funny because it's like oh
that's your best shot
that's your that's what you got oh yeah
i remember one time yeah dude called me
inward and i laughed and he was even
more pissed it was some dude that i
don't know he he did something i i think
we were fighting
and he dropped it and i just laughed and
i was like
so he didn't call you he just he said it
out loud when people were friends no you
called it to me to you yeah yeah when's
the last time like you've experienced
something like that what someone call me
the n word what just rate like racism in
general like that to that extent yeah i
mean online these [ __ ] well i mean
really face-to-face hey i mean it was a
long time ago i mean
yeah so like no i'm saying like dude i
remember this one story where was i at i
was in uh
it was when i was going to school in
kentucky
and i didn't have enough money to go
home for christmas set that year
and so i went to a friend's house in
like northern
virginia which i think was close to like
west super uh close to west virginia
yeah i remember she invited me
to this party right
uh it was like some graduation party or
something and i walk in obviously only
black dude and this was like this party
she invited me to
was like in the middle of [ __ ]
nowhere so i was like bro i don't know i
don't know these [ __ ] backwoods i
don't know how to like give some [ __ ]
popped off because you think that yeah
you know i mean that's fair
you just think that because you know i'm
like i don't know yeah and plus i had
never been out that way you know what i
mean so
i remember
i walked into the party and it was like
it's i don't know if it was it was like
someone's graduation party you know
because you know you can graduate in
december sometimes from college
and i walk right in
and i was and i just came in as like
happy to go lucky as i am because i was
like well if
if my friend invited me to this party
then i'm safe yeah you're probably
welcome yeah exactly i'm probably
welcome
and i walk in and i was like hey where's
the food at and this dude looks at me he
goes food's over there boy
straight up
straight up and i kind of was just like
yeah well i'm only 22. that's all i said
i was like yeah i'm only 22. i just try
to like you know yeah go past it or
whatever
and then you know i'm sitting there
throughout the night and then they
started you know i'm getting the looks
but then they started warming up to me
and then this one dude i mean i never
forget he was in overalls big
[ __ ] get big sounds about right
exactly right she's country bumpkin
[ __ ] right
and he goes
uh he goes hey let me tell you a little
history
and i was like
yeah i know right right there right
there you're like
and so uh
i was like i was like i wanted to teach
you history yeah yeah it's like uh
enlighten me you know come on come over
over here and he goes he put out a
quarter
nickel dime and a penny
right
and on the quarter nickel
diamond penny
the quarter the silver is it silver
whatever the [ __ ] it is it was they're
facing that way
and then the people came facing the
other face the other way right and they
were like why why is that
i was like i don't know
i don't know
[ __ ] it i i have no clue i was like just
just throw it at me and they were like
uh
they're turning because they're turning
he said because they're turning their
backs on lincoln for freeing the slaves
also american history also the funniest
brown i
because he goes what's the difference i
was like oh the pennies
like like i was thinking of the pennies
brown like oh you're probably saying
something i knew he was going somewhere
racially yeah you know what i mean and
like it's weird because when you get in
that situation
you have like two options it's like okay
i'm outnumbered
mm-hmm but also at the same time i got
to survive
so i was just like hey man that's crazy
[Laughter]
at any point did you look at your friend
like hey i'm uncomfortable can we no
because she wasn't around she was she
was somewhere she was in like another
room yeah and it was just me and these
like country bumpkins oh i hate that if
i go to a party with someone i have to
be attached to you well like i wasn't
too frightened because i'm like they
would have done something already yeah
you know what i mean i was like they
would they would they would have popped
off immediately and also i just don't
assume
all the time that people are like
racist or just like you know
or anything and even if they are like i
know i mean i know how to talk my way
out of a situation
you know what i mean and also like like
i'm of no threat
to these [ __ ] i was in a v-neck
and skinny jeans what the [ __ ] am i
gonna do you know what i mean like
as far as they're concerned but i mean
you would [ __ ]
what did you say you could them them up
really badly oh yeah i totally could but
i mean
five of these [ __ ] you know
they're some big dudes you know what i
mean and meanwhile and then she took me
to a different party in a trailer park
she was taking me everywhere what did
you know bruh and i'll tell you what
like squid games
it was insane dude
rally after no i don't want to tell them
the story too but uh
she she took me to this other party in
the trailer park
and i was like okay this is this is
going to be insane why didn't i walk
agreeing to go to these parties because
i don't give a [ __ ] you know i don't
know i just i was with her i never been
out there okay and so
as soon as i walk in
i just see a fatty confederate flag and
i was like oh [ __ ] oh yeah
like this is going to be a long time
you know and so all i did was just sit
there
in the middle of like the party and i
meet this big dude
he was like he's uh he lifted rocks
was just that was his [ __ ] job
yeah he goes not like strong man like he
doesn't know i don't know that was his
[ __ ] i don't know someone
[ __ ] machines and [ __ ] you know he
just lifts rocks and moves them around
and [ __ ] something weird like that
anyways i remember
there's this dude in there
and he dropped the end bomb
and he dropped it [ __ ]
hard r
and he was like and i don't care that
he's sitting there and i was like
i was like oh god like what the [ __ ]
what was he talking about though i don't
remember i just know there was he was in
an argument with his girlfriend or
something weird
like where it was like crazy and i
remember
but what was cool is like all the other
white like majority of the white people
in that
facility are in that trailer
that's apt
in that facility we're like
hey man
you know like we're sorry yeah we
apologize
for or whatever and meanwhile like
i don't give a [ __ ] like what like also
like hey
like i said i gotta [ __ ] survive
you know what i mean i'm just like
[Music]
they used to say it like that you know i
mean like because it's [ __ ] weird
you know like you just but like i would
say that was probably like when i think
about
racism that was probably like some of
the craziest
[ __ ] that i've ever dealt with can i
make an abrupt transition yeah
transition
that's rough stuff you guys got stoves
you guys got you guys got stoves yeah
yeah you cook with you in the kitchen
yeah you guys got you guys yeah
yeah uh what is the back of it like like
so like how thick is it
like can you could you put stuff on top
of
no mine isn't actually that thick like i
like salt pepper what a perfect answer
cat well now you can really
why why is that
it's called stove show
are you serious oh my god i i've been
needing
hey this is the best transition
my favorite part about it he goes uh man
that's crazy stop that
it happened to you man wild um
yeah
look at that oh look at that that is
incredible oh [ __ ] that's a bad okay
there we go that was my fault yeah
um
uh it doesn't sit perfectly on the table
because the table is not a stove exactly
uh
seasonings uh cooking spray what's that
picture right there um so okay so
history of stove shelf it's my buddy
from university of minnesota scott
fleming uh scott fleming he's like a
talented like i don't know he was like
an engineer or like chemist or something
yeah
he he did he did research as his
full-time job for a while but then after
a drunken research after drunken night
out he's uh dinking around in his wood
shop and he put together the original
stove shelf he just put some wood
together and he put some magnets on it
because he was tired of stuff falling
behind his stove yeah uh and he fixed it
and then he he started to make it and
he's manufacturing them and like
he's absolutely crushing like i've just
been following on instagram and like oh
he's like oh i sold 30 stove shelves
today and then like six months later
it's like this giant pallet of stove
shelves yeah and now he's like so you
saw the growth organic yeah and now he's
and now he's like oh i need to hire an
employee for my warehouse of stuff
see look at that that's so convenient
and uh so everybody got it has a stove
shelf we have six uh the original
stainless steel how to take this one
home uh if you want stainless steel but
there's also white and black
so there's options at variety yeah and
it comes in three uh
sizes of
24
27 and 30 inches i think 30 inches
standard i think that's what we got
so uh yeah if you do have a curved one
on the off chance you have a curved one
then stove shelf might not be right for
you
yet results may vary
so use promo code uh
oh [ __ ]
it looks pretty easy to clean too use
promo code dark
for your uh
either stainless steel i think you're
black and white
or you're screwed if you have a curved
you're screwed if you have a curved top
well you probably don't have a curved
top so it's fine
30 inches some other models right
different you're also screwed if you've
got a curved dick you know what i mean
like that's some girls like that some
girls like that yeah they like a little
bit of a curve my mind might be bigger
which way it curves yeah oh the curves
up right yes
yeah it curves down it curves down
towards him we're about to transition to
ass eating aren't we
christian always finds meanwhile get
your stainless steel
put the ass on the stovetop put the ass
on the stovetop you can do whatever the
hell you want with this use promo code
dark
when uh going to purchase your stove
shelf oh yeah here it is top
maximize your kitchen storage wood stove
oh stove stove shelf and i would love
gosh they make it easy to say huh i
would love if everybody brought in
a stove or no had someone record had
someone record them
uh installing their stove shelf got it
uh and we i want to use those videos
that's a [ __ ] magnet i think
it's really
easy i know but that that's that's the
point of the video it's 50 i'm going to
use all my stuff yeah hey look at me oh
yeah they're the color color ones
wow
i'm just kidding
you guys i
[Laughter]
you know what drives me crazy because i
watch everybody get uncomfortable can we
stop telling people uh whenever they say
something funny or stupid that oh that's
racist and they're like oh i didn't edit
you know can we stop doing that to
people or or people do we have to do it
i think we have to do it okay we're
super open here we don't care yeah if
it's it's a joke if it's funny it's not
being hurtful yeah it's all good
i feel like in here people just get
quiet when it's not a good joke not
necessarily
no one's ever complained
yeah you're talking about society
[Music]
[ __ ] i'll throw this bottle at you you
know what i mean shut up
let people live
because most people aren't trying to be
[ __ ] racist huh not even the guy that
dropped the n-bomb in uh that that
trailer park
[Laughter]
i mean he just didn't know i was there
that's awesome
sounds like you just went to a clan
meeting yeah
you were the guest of honor does uh
thick boy have a
uh p.o box
i think sorry so we do right no we've
just been getting like any mail we've
gotten like it's just come straight to
the studio yeah which is kind of tricky
yeah so i i yeah because i want to do
the handwritten letter thing but i
i almost put my own address i was going
to say p.o box and then put one of the
addresses but i also don't want to put
the studio huh so no uh but i want to
figure that out they're [ __ ] actually
like weirdly complicated yet you have to
like go down there chad had to do that
yeah
figure it out i had to do that once for
the old studio but we don't have it
anymore oh yeah oh i thought it was
because like only fans that fans wanted
to send you [ __ ] oh no i don't accept
stuff like that from uh people yeah
smart like if they said the mobile
that's also what i was thinking about
yeah like if someone was in the mold no
this was back when i was oh yes some
people do that some people will make
molds of their partner's penis and uses
a dildo oh so you got them right in the
mail yeah that's a thing some people
make their own flashlights too because
they're they're probably like you know i
just don't want to cheat on my
significant other so i'm gonna get his
dildo or his dick molded into a dildo is
that what they do
maybe i could see that yeah you know
what i could absolutely see that being
able to say hey talking take that big
black dildo
and shove it up your ass
yeah there we go that's one of them
[Laughter]
so you just put your willy inside of
that too gigantic in like some sort of
like
liquid that will mold into it all right
that one's smaller that's so stupid
backwards no
you know what hey it's not stupid you
know what
people people like to have their [ __ ]
you know i just feel like that's just a
whole process to do
yeah i mean that's a lot of dedication
could you imagine like putting
medication
[Music]
like how long does your dick have to sit
in a cast for and is it like no
i feel like you can't keep it in there
for too long oh so okay so you're
probably not putting your flaccid dick
in there right no you gotta i feel like
you gotta get hard how long do you have
to stay hard until that like sets take a
bluetooth or something i don't uh i
don't know
i have so many logistical questions yeah
there's so much to it yeah it yeah it is
very interesting
what were you talking about before this
i don't know hey get your stainless
steel uh your
[ __ ] um your skill shot
stove stove shelf
that is crazy we were talking about
boxes cause we're trying to do hand
letters we want people to write hand
letters
don't we have a p.o box at the old
kinglessing studio did we get rid of
that when we moved studios
yeah didn't we have a p.o box at the old
studio nick for king to sing
no we just used the studio address
good evening good evening yeah i'm out
of claw
[Laughter]
i always applause too i took two girls
yeah are you uh
you a whiskey guy in general yeah i i
don't really like
as discussed i don't really go out and
like i drink white cloth when we record
like the other shows that i do because
white cloth is safe huh
huh the alcohol percentage is a great
yeah right it's like a beer no calories
you know uh alcohol percentage in texas
and texas beers are higher uh i've heard
it i knew it did state by state yeah and
sometimes in wisconsin depending on
where you buy it from like if you get it
from a gas station it's 3.2
but if you get it from a liquor store
you need a license to sell anything
above 3.2 and they oh god same beer a
miller lite from a liquor store
different than a million light from guys
you ever been to appleton wisconsin uh
actually no no green bay you've been in
green bay yeah appleton is uh
yeah you know what i mean oh yeah
wisconsin yeah
that was
listen i had a great time doing the
shows there and the people were great
but but
that town they were drinking no no it
was tough to be in oh
lacrosse or like some of the college
towns are like there's more nightlife
going on and stuff yeah but it also gets
like [ __ ] sloppy
downtown like
your downtown gets sloppy yeah i mean
you guys saw him in the bro oh yeah oh
you're on the bride and then you got the
groom
yeah
yeah that was a tough one
she she tried to stab him or her oh no
she tried to hit him with her heel they
started saying something about
trump or they had
i can't remember wasn't that was it a
racist thing yeah it was a racist thing
this whole this was like they deserved i
know what the hell is
magic
magic
magic mine stove shells
[Laughter]
for two companies that aren't afraid of
the issues
against
full back season
[Laughter]
we're trying to make a change
okay so
[Laughter]
if we did some sort of game
and whoever
i miss our favorite my favorite game
which one the the you know what i'm
talking about the thing you sport sport
here we go we gotta play some sparkle
and we gotta zoom people in would you
guys play a game and whoever lost has to
eat a hot ship i will
a hot chip i have to go i have to go
back yeah i'm gonna do it but i think
yeah we just watched it yeah are you
watching yeah just like a couple days
ago i may have one chip in my bag oh
it's not as exciting when you want to
take it
a very quick and change
for him how he feels about that chip i
just don't think he realizes because we
might get none of us
i'm gonna do it
no reason to disrespect i know
special announcement our third sponsor
[Laughter]
meatball you're really gonna do it
i don't like how he's recording me
no you're gonna be great uh you're on a
podcast dude eight that's fine hey nick
you know what's so funny when i think
back to that episode you know how many
people like whenever i'm doing shows and
like
meet and greets and [ __ ] you know how
many people come to me go hey remember
when you told theo that he cries pretty
yeah
wait so do i have to eat the entire
thing
the whole chip is it at least does it at
least taste good yeah can we give you a
tip though
don't keep chewing it swallow it as fast
as you can
do not get the
your eyes don't touch your power
wash your hands afterwards so eat it and
then wash your hands and then also the
actual chip challenge which we did not
do on the show is to try not to drink
anything
yeah i read that i thought we did that
are you gonna do that no we all drank we
drink milk are you going to do that
we'll see
you're going to just eat it and see how
you're quitter if you drink something
but just as long as we're in agreement
hey don't touch your [ __ ] hands
this is initiation meatball there you go
do it for a road yeah you're lucky we're
not beating the [ __ ] out of you you just
have to eat the chips
has a lot of experience with that huh
what no
i was never a gang member right
only adjacent right
[ __ ] it
you're down i'll tell you that
start the much
so far so good remember if you can
swallow it right
yeah get some saliva do you taste it at
all the flavor i don't remember if there
was a flavor to it it's just spicy nasty
to me that ship was bought at the same
time the ones we ate
that's a good thing that's good because
the spices start dying down too
the spices will go yeah the spices will
start leaving
yeah after a while it starts to get like
painful it's
terrible about how bad it gets you know
we don't have to not
no but you're gonna you're it's too late
now you're gonna tell me make sure you
don't touch your face or anything you're
doing great so far
right now yeah go wash your hands
with this last time we'll see uh
christian
oh it didn't hit until like a little bit
right for me it didn't hit until maybe
like
two to three minutes in the real pain
we were all scared too because our
stomachs didn't feel right yeah i felt
like maybe for me it didn't mess up my
stomach it's just like chappelle
hey i ain't the whole thing it's not
immediately nice look at his face
you see that like christian carbonated
oh yeah there you go dude now you should
get a magic mushroom magic uh magic mine
magic mine yeah
christian i'm putting a link on the uh
the rundown that i gave oh here we go
you got it you got it you got it all
right now you got hey name 10 cereals
see that's hilarious we started doing
that and pull up that lid cereals pop
that link yeah
10 cereals
ready set go i'm on your side christian
honey nut cheerios frosted flakes
um cocoa pebbles
cocoa puffs fruity pebbles
uh apple jacks
honey nut cheerios you already named
that one um yeah you already said honey
uh honey bunches of oats
uh reese's puffs captain crunch
he's good uh where am i at i think he's
actually honestly helping him think
about how much it burns
[Laughter]
up yeah this kind of makes sense i feel
like this is how nick feels on the
inside 24 7. christian's always taking
some sort of like upper stimulant so i
feel like this is great for him it just
like zeroes in no burning it off yeah
it's not great good one
oh nice
i hate you all fingers so on the run
down
you might have to refresh it if it
doesn't show up right away
look at this it's just that youtube link
you can always tell when christian's
eyes are anybody's not feeling okay i'm
not feeling okay
oh wow so the 360 challenge i i said
this was filmed on uh do you have any
gum in here
and could you go to like uh 21 minutes
so this is a 360.
of us doing the uh
the one chip challenge and you can like
drag the the view around if you click in
the middle of the screen and hold wait
why was that guy on screen and just play
and i thought
he was uh
like the submission as we're like dying
i tried to like bring up a video and he
was just like [ __ ] that guy dude but
like move around the room christian yeah
you can go all the way around
it's so dope yeah oh there's [ __ ] i
don't know
that's what i only took a
look at me oh yeah give me that gatorade
christian passed away
christian come back it's just a fun
thing to review we're i think we got to
release this for free on the king and
the stuff yeah i thought it was going to
come out oh he was still on patreon that
was a patreon yeah
the 360 was we had that for maybe like
10 episodes and it's actually super cool
especially if you had an oculus you
could just be like
an oculus ain't that the [ __ ] they gave
you in school
that's inoculations
and oculus is that thing that
people run into the wall with you know
what i mean
i can't believe i did
and i think i said it wrong but i know
what you mean inoculation
i don't even know what you're saying
this is when you still weren't eating
rice right but yeah i just wanted to i
plugged that 360 thing okay um
nothing specific to show i think it's
dope
feel his face
when does this go away you can pop you
can pause
he starts to die down around the five
minute mark
yeah long die down how's your stomach
right now
yeah your stomach's probably gonna be
[ __ ] up for the rest of the day
it's so crazy that he's drink a sprite
like there's no water here that's fair
whose fault is that christian not mine
yes it is that's like that that could be
a responsibility you take on here i
don't want to big brother you but oh
yeah so what you would say is like hey
we need more water for the studio can i
get some and then
bill you know burn
yeah that's what you
[ __ ] about that right now i'm dying i
really don't give a
flying this should be the most
this should be how you're hearing me
you're the most affected by it right now
see that's how i feel hey the first time
i took magic mind that's what i felt and
i never did that's what i felt but in a
good way the positive way that's what i
felt
all i know is i'm gonna drive home with
my head out the window
oh like uh it'll go away
by the end of this you'll feel yeah i
don't know if you'll feel fine you'll
see ace ventura
yeah he does that he drives with his
head out the window
dude no one else could have [ __ ]
played that role he's amazing think
about it who else could have [ __ ]
done ace ventura yeah there's gonna
don't lie or liar
the physical comedy in those movies is
like
incredible like there's no [ __ ] way
his expressions like no one can the way
he does his expressions is like the mask
everything
like he goes [ __ ] ball who could have
played that character and they better
not try to make a [ __ ] remake they
probably will
be the stupidest [ __ ] if they try to
make a remake of that with him still or
someone else it was someone else or
either because when he's in stuff you
can see how old he looks now
and i just it's just commercial for
cable management yes
commercial for cable guy a super bowl
commercial and but he just looked old
she did the character yeah
like he was just like came to someone's
game remember i mean
who or the commercial even dumb and dumb
i heard that was terrible i didn't watch
it though um
[ __ ] why am i blanking on his name
who jim carrey jim carrey i said jamie
uh jim carrey cable guy see there he
looks all this [ __ ] that was actually
good yeah it's about to stop it good job
all that [ __ ] i'm sorry
we remember his character
there's nothing wrong with he's aging uh
but i just don't want to see him but do
the same roles yeah it like bumps me out
we remember him as yeah i want him as
newer roles i don't want them to go back
and touch
stuff
yeah also like i don't think there's
[ __ ]
these gen zeros
are going to understand
you know oh like you understand female
artists
i'll represent dumb and dumber like for
generations when i have a child i cannot
wait to watch oh yeah yeah when i went
back for thanksgiving my nephews were
like 11 and 13
and we like fell asleep watching tommy
boy it was [ __ ] awesome yeah they
love tommy boy they can which one okay i
always get them mixed up
black sheep which one was tommy boy
tommy boy is callahan auto parts they
sell the brake pads they go across
country together yes yes black sheep is
you know my favorite part of that movie
is when it gets pulled over and the
officer officer goes you know how fast
you're going he was like
70 80 tops he goes seven
did they get high were they high yeah
yeah
yeah
because he was going real slow he was
like 70 80 tops
i like that one snl sketch uh chris
marley would do where he was like
remember that time you were in the
beatles
yeah yeah
oh [ __ ]
guys there's so much [ __ ] production
here yeah
sorry about that i hope i didn't [ __ ] up
yeah the crown the crown is a skewb
behind a cat
oh yeah it is what is behind me uh
lightning bolt
oh and pre and soon to be a wing
some place yeah where will the wind go i
think right here but they they
uh
they sat in different spots for the
upcoming they keep doing it yeah
there's like a musical chairs thing
going on which is kind of funny should
you just have a detachable and like put
wherever he sits they already announced
it right i like it in theory but i would
have to do it yes
i was like nah it's not my deal if it
wasn't my job then sure they already
announced it right uh yes yeah okay cool
i know if we could talk about it
patriot.com catsplus
yeah
i like cats plus it's like a name
because like that's a great name
yes no that's dope that's good
cats plus
you know what i mean
what are you guys doing uh not mine are
you [ __ ] feeling it
okay
she's like not that bad though
my stomach hurts now yeah that's what
happens a guy might puke after this hey
christian
did you eat today sorry no you're good
go ahead all right did you eat today
that's probably that's when i think it
really [ __ ] up your stomach yeah you
can just feel it tearing at your inner
linings i remember yesterday
[Laughter]
how's that mouth
why'd you say it like that yeah that's
so sexual you got a pretty mouth
there's something about the hot chips
that makes your pal a little more
a little squirrely
i love the clip they made of that when
uh i was like deal you cried pretty and
it just was like yeah
because that moment just stopped in time
[Laughter]
i don't know what i meant that was these
people are ugly criers yeah that's what
i was trying to say
it's true right
i i there's
my lighting is all over the place as you
have uh have seen
but uh there's some episodes that i just
like remember seeing and i love i like
like what brendan and theo were wearing
and i loved the lighting and that one
was like really bright and yeah
you had a dodgers uniform on and brandon
else brandon had something the whole
episode i [ __ ] loved yeah and uh he
did like he just had like a nice sheen
dude
because i tell you what a year ago no
one [ __ ] backed me up on that
it was for the baby
if he cried ugly i'm like damn you cry
ugly yeah yeah but i gave him credit and
said he cried pretty
observation look at that stove shelf all
right it looks great
what are you thinking about right now
not to throw up hey man
that was a good idea having to take it
really
well i think i think it just made you
know i think it solidified your spot
you know yeah like a an official
initiation association
yeah i'd rather not be initiated so
funny
okay then mommy back that magic my money
christian when i when i did it i [ __ ]
uh
ate like part of the chip and it [ __ ]
me up you know because i thought you
didn't even eat the whole trip no i
didn't at first
and then we noticed that he didn't eat
the whole chip because i thought
everybody just took a bite no we took
the whole thing
and chapelle was like the most vocal too
about how i was like oh he's like a
small guy and he was crying he was
wailing on the floor
[Applause]
but then when i ate that full
[ __ ] oh
it doesn't help that it tastes like ass
too you know it doesn't taste great when
theo was like hold it up hold it up away
from your body
[Laughter]
years ago
uh the years ago the rapper years ago
they tried to that [ __ ] i just
texted marshall the other day
i was just checking in trying to get him
on i realized i had like a draft
because he told i asked him if you want
we wanted to fly him out and he's like
my he was like my dad just died from
covington a month ago uh this was two
this is like a year and a half ago and
oh that's why he didn't come out yeah
and i had like a draft like i'm so so
sorry like um wishing you family to pass
whatever but i didn't send it and i
literally went to text him just to like
kind of follow up after two years he
just kind of like was gonna check in
like a sight and scene but like the last
thing was him sending that and then me
not saying anything it just made me look
like a
careless yeah yeah okay you don't you're
not gonna be on then then like whatever
but uh
i think i was just more thinking about
how i was word wording it but um yeah i
did that she wanted to fly out he didn't
that's a bummer
i get why he didn't want to fly out then
yeah
why are you twisting the knife brother
no yeah yeah yeah i don't know i guess i
was just thinking i didn't really like
that
my delivery was a stove shelf
some magic mine magic mine stove shelf
yes oh good idea
no
yeah just be like oh we want to send you
a gift yeah yeah like cat's family is
thinking about them
just in case he has doesn't have a stove
we find something
bro who don't have a stove i don't know
i was just kidding uh i always all i was
trying to say is like something else
that he might kind of like get and be
excited about where his stove shelf
might need a little explanation
maybe i could send him the clip maybe we
could maybe we could just
maybe we could just buy him studio time
oh
he has a heat right now though how the
heat heat's gone i just feel like i'm
gonna throw up oh at least the heat's
gone
i would rather it be back really then
deal with having her throw up yeah
i think he took it pretty well all
things considered you did better than
the chipotle you did way better than me
yeah
i ran out of the room
oh yeah and nick gave you and brandon
like warm milk because it had been
sitting out for me
i forgot in my car and then i post mince
milk so we got cold milk but like
but by then the guys are already sick
yeah you don't care he was like give me
the warm milk uh
that's awesome
does the milk actually help because i'll
go [ __ ] i mean it's not milk but i'll go
stick my tongue in that ice cream in the
fridge right now yeah because what's
burning you is the acidity in the chip
and milk is basic it's a basic ph level
so
yeah that's it wow
yo
do it over him
nick knows all this [ __ ] uh what was it
oh
we should brainstorm who we want to try
to get in studio for a guest next week
one person i do want to uh have back in
who i loved uh and i loved that episode
because we did it in the new studio in
the big room white mike
oh he's great oh yeah yeah
yeah dude he's great he's great and i
love that cats after dark yeah um he
lives here
well he's my roommate
still yeah yeah oh wow yeah what kind of
oh wow
i don't know i thought you lived with
your girlfriend i guess i didn't know i
didn't know he was in town so yeah
you're like oh yeah i can easily get him
yeah he's playing right up the street so
let's not put him on the wish list
because that's a we can easily get yeah
who would like i feel like we can that
we know denzel washington or that would
be cool or we know
eventually i want to have the scissors
i didn't mean the who like that oh i
kind of feel like uh rudy would be cool
rudy from uh bad friends oh that's a
great idea i feel like she hasn't really
done like a podcast podcast she's always
kind of been like the third mic
it'd be cool to get her on i love that
i actually don't know her oh really yeah
no i just like watch from afar got you
yeah i love what i love what they do too
yeah that's a good crossover they're
behind the scenes are behind the scenes
yeah exactly uh i like it i was thinking
i thought she was talking about the dude
that played rudy uh oh yeah we get him
too that'd be cool have you ever seen
that movie the hobbit hey meatball maybe
it's just so adorable meatball rudy
that's your [ __ ] movie
that's about you do you have you seen
that movie yeah
yeah my number in high school was 45
i didn't realize it at the time
dude this is kind of this is kind of
incredible we should actually give him a
chap at the beginning of every episode
you're doing a great job
whoever gave you that number just you
know they oh they yeah whoever they knew
exactly what they were doing
hang on is that the only reason why you
know the movie too no i saw it oh yeah
it's oh i i know it was like
they gave you the number 45 you're like
what the [ __ ] is everyone laughing at me
and then you watch the movie no i i
chose the number 45 my freshman year you
didn't get to choose your number
i was 43.
then you grew two inches so you went to
four or five exactly
exactly okay nick with the slicer
last week uh her videos two weeks ago
what i i don't know
i had sick burn on me but his face got
so sad and i just felt so bad i
immediately apologized in the moment but
even watching it back i felt bad
i remember
so well it was like the first or second
episode i used it as a cold open yeah
oh yeah
i think someone said this episode's
getting spicy
i'll start off
there he is wow
that guy's like
yo
don't put [ __ ] christian's face
on the [ __ ] cover of rudy right i
mean i don't know any [ __ ] photo
shoppers but i haven't funny i know a
lot of you catch that [ __ ] listen to
this [ __ ] yeah that's that's the type of
[ __ ] we want is that a sack is that
meatball getting a sack right there i
think it's him trying to get a sack
i don't know i was credited with it
though yeah it was a great effort
you're really putting your all into it
love it
yeah we gotta get you photoshopped on
that i can do that oh you do it yeah no
he's learning a lot of stuff now
whatever meatball [ __ ] me yeah huh
maybe i will oh
let's fight that's it
what is it about this chip the
homoeroticism hey he said it he says
or whatever he said i don't know what he
said he said he grabbed me or something
like that
i get a very strong like enemies to
lovers trope with you and christian
like in a movie yeah we're strong
enemies
i bet we get every guest that i have on
chappelle's world probably gets caught
off guard because most of the time me
and christian are just talking [ __ ] to
each other whoa most of the time during
the episode i'll just be sitting there
not do not saying anything and all
sudden chappelle would just look at me
and go [ __ ] you
i was randomly in the middle of the
episode i'm like what did i do no no no
it's just because he looks at me crazy
it's just me looking he'll be like
and that's what i'll be like [ __ ] you
come on christian you know wow does
everyone have chappelle wrong is he
actually the villain in all of this
genius people think i'm like the nice
guy yeah i am nice yeah you are
what have i done that was me
don't answer that
everyone else can answer
i said i'll just put our group chat on
on display you don't have to put grooves
out you use a [ __ ] arch
[Laughter]
you okay there you go take it back take
those [ __ ] hits i haven't seen
someone caught from weed in a minute
dawg
you know what i mean that's that's when
you hit it real good
get that [ __ ] i might have to send
you that brian to make that a sick rap
yeah there's this show this thing on
that we do on another podcast show
called
yeah just when someone takes a hit and
it's usually me uh we just like look in
the camera like blow it out and he adds
all these effects and it's crazy yeah
and uh actually do you can you find the
uh time code of the sick rip at the
feldman show
oh yeah yeah let's get started it's
gonna take a second
when's the last time y'all seen someone
[ __ ] take a puff and cough from it oh
that's like me because i don't smoke or
anything i used to try to take hits out
of my ex-boyfriend's vape and it was so
strong that i just hacked
vapes are terrifying yeah the vape [ __ ]
that's all i really know i'm terrifying
that's the favorite no no i'm talking
about like not this not this [ __ ] but
that's weird right yeah but
people were saying when usually when
people are saying vaping
nicotine not like yeah
terrifying brutal oh that's well i mean
it [ __ ] terrified me but i get
terrified of everything yeah including
magic i know but uh promo car code dark
yeah dark but yeah i get terrified of
[ __ ] everything but that that [ __ ]
and it burned my hand i would burn your
hair uh yeah that happens every now and
then when you try to mod it my
ex-boyfriend was really big into getting
different types of vapes and he'd mod it
himself to make it stronger so the smoke
would come out a lot like uh i
understand why it's your ex-boyfriend
yeah
[Music]
and sometimes it would start to like go
off and like smoke like his pants caught
on fire that's what i'm saying it's like
who created that that was the best you
can [ __ ] do this is my favorite
battery this is my only vape battery i
don't know
about when i thought my ex-boyfriend is
cheating on me and he was at a vape
contest
a contest speaking of which uh i told
this story to my friend recently and i
didn't think it was weird until i said
it out loud but my my ex-boyfriend and i
were like on and off at this time and he
was really big into vaping but i thought
he was gonna go see another [ __ ] so
what i did was i
waited outside of his house for him to
leave and i followed him to wherever he
was going i did not tell a singer
no no he didn't and i drove a yellow
mini cooper so that's his own fault yeah
um so i followed him to this like strip
mall in milpitas and i was looking
around like what [ __ ] is he meeting
here like i don't understand what's
happening and he walks into this crowded
store and i just see a bunch of men
inside and i'm a little confused i look
up like oh it's a vape shop okay well
like maybe he's hanging out with a girl
here
and then i'm watching like 30 minutes in
him just like
hanging out with a bunch of dudes
wearing a bunch of like yeah a bunch of
like
very large
like asian samoan men who are vaping and
they're doing a vape contest where it's
basically two guys with their modded
vapes that they have created themselves
essentially they go back to back like a
shootout they take a puff of this vape
and then blow it in the air whoever has
the biggest longest vape wins like a
fifty dollar gift card
and
i remember being so stressed like oh my
god this is the love of my life he's
gonna go and [ __ ] another [ __ ] and he's
in this like seedy s part of town with a
bunch of like large sweaty men in levi's
like levi to levi rubbing asses
to win 50 to this [ __ ] vape shop and
in that moment like i something clicked
into me like 50
yeah in my head i was like what the [ __ ]
am i doing i'm stressing over this man
who is
out of vape competition and lost this is
like exact same scene out of knocked up
when uh leslie mann thinks paul rudd is
cheating and they walk in sneak in the
house and it's a fantasy football
contest
it's a fancy picture i wish it was a
fantasy baseball i wish it was fantasy
baseball it was a vape competition for a
gift card that he lost
like i don't i got matsui yeah so
what led you to believe that he might be
cheating um i was just wildly insecure
and thought he had so many options now
looking back at that moment i i didn't
have anything to worry about but like
what does that mean that means a lot
no back then i was catened i would i was
not [ __ ]
i was not cat i still don't think i'm
[ __ ] but i was like in this situation
where i thought like oh my god like he
can have any [ __ ] he wants and now i'm
looking back like no he couldn't granted
he's a very nice guy everything's cool
but like
i really thought that
he was like out here cheating on me and
i showed up like oh i'm at an all-time
low and i never told anyone it took me
how were you i was about
20 like just turned 20. this is the
boyfriend of six years uh no of nine
years old in hindsight would you have
rather him cheated on you then uh
looking back at it now
no because i feel like that
that little like nerdy bit of him is
what i really loved i love nerdy boys
who are just like very pure
hearted kind of like oh i'm just like
doing my own thing like
i i really like guys that i feel like
most other girls do not like that's kind
of my type that's fair yeah i like the
nerdy guys the guys who like don't
really have too much going on
they're just like they've always been
very nice to me i used to be a chubby
girl yeah and the nerdy guys were always
very nice so do you think being like uh
being single helped you find your
security
uh i think
finding my security came from when i
started working a lot of jobs and i was
like take care of me and him i was like
oh i don't need him for [ __ ] that's
where like my sense of self came in i
was like oh
i don't need any man for anything you
know there you go nick nick is it yeah
yeah there we go
yeah yeah queen yeah queen speaking of
fat clouds oh yeah let's see this fat
cloud
[Laughter]
and then they immediately
i go i'm sorry
[Laughter]
with such
did he have an opener well because he
kind of went dave matthews here so
everybody was chilled out
did he have an opener uh no
is that george from tigerville
he played six songs and that was it
yeah it was just it was just him
yeah oh wow it was uh well i mean dj
angel courtney
played a dj set before and then she
closed the show and i shut down the
dance floor is that his girlfriend
that's his wife now his wife yeah she's
hot he said he said former angel
would you like a victorian secret model
yeah
i don't know he's got corey's angels
yeah yeah and uh he's got what um
like charlie's angels yeah
basically just girls that naturally
adore him that he just has around him uh
but uh yeah she graduated from angel to
wife he sounds like he has a lot of
yes men
around him oh yeah
oh big time to where he's just like
just so yeah
i mean because i mean who i mean
if any of y'all ever did that i mean
like hey chin no
that's my passion don't do it that way
don't do it that way like [ __ ] don't
you're not michael jackson
like it's just [ __ ] insane do you
think corey's aware that he has a lot of
yes men in his corner i'm always
confused on whether the people who have
yes men around them know are aware of it
or they're just oblivious to the fact
that everyone's like
riding their coattails saying i think he
i think he's killing he's oblivious yeah
i bet britney spears had a lot of
[ __ ] yes men around her
yeah i could see that i could also see
her having a lot of like
like manipulative yes man yeah whereas
i think most people are there for their
own gain yeah oh she actually got a 50
million dollar book deal to uh
in like reaction to her sister's failed
book
i'm happy about that damn her sister had
a failure yeah because her sister
decided to write her own memoir and i
guess the original title was going to be
something along the lines of a britney
lyric like uh
like and no one supported her yeah and
no uh she already came out with it she
came out with it and it was she said
like oh this book is about me and my
life not my sisters but in the book she
names brittany like 150 something times
[ __ ] don't use my name yeah and so
britney had to send out like a cease and
desist and it was like a hot ass mess
but shortly after uh brittany was
had like this huge book like book deal
in place where she got 15 million
dollars for it so now she's writing her
own memoir what's her sister named zoe
uh i know that's uh her show her name is
jamie lynn spears yeah see i don't even
know that i don't even know her
yeah give it a goog
girl give it a go
he has no idea he's lost
google jamie lynn
spears
yeah it's uh yeah you know i always
that situation is so [ __ ] wild yeah
but also like at the same time i'm like
i don't really
care see i have such an emotional title
when i was younger she was my favorite
artist i wanted to be renamed to britney
lee because no one could say cat teen
growing up and i love britney spears so
now whenever i'm in the house if i talk
about brittany stevie's like adamantly
against brittany he says that she's a
crazy lady who needs to like be in a
mental institution and i
want to physically hit him did y'all see
that you see the picture she posted like
it was like oh yeah yeah
andrew schultz had the best line for it
he goes y'all heard that an apology
i haven't stopped thinking about it
because every time i think about that
picture
y'all heard that an apology
click that one christian
click on one be engaged
he can't even think right now
so they're not tied at all
uh no i don't think they are oh jamie
lynn's cute these are all yeah these i
mean
she looks good there
is she the same age as us
wait you're younger ages
i'm 34. i think i think i think she's in
her early 30s now wait wait you just
turned 34 nick
oh she just day after christmas okay
oh 30.
she's gonna turn 31
and she tried to come out with a book
and they were like nah [ __ ] you [ __ ]
your books suck
yeah basically is it bad it didn't do
well dude because it's like no one
i'm sorry i mean jamie spirits i hope
you don't take this personal because i
know you listen but
like no one [ __ ] people stop thinking
about you when you had that baby you
know what i'm saying it's also rough
cat's like i have the body i'm and i'm
you know the disrespect i have the book
no uh i think it's rough for her to try
to come out and do something like that
when you know
the person you're going up against has a
fan base like britney spears that's
that's the roughest part jake gyllenhaal
came out and made a statement about
taylor swift and her fan base because
she released the 10-minute version of a
song dragging him he was like oh i have
no problem with taylor like the problem
is with her fan base like they take it
too far
so like the swifties yes
it is you know what that is i feel like
that's a big feat to try to get to where
you're like taking on her family okay
well first of all with the jake
gyllenhaal thing are they just [ __ ]
with them online
uh yeah it's it's a lot of like [ __ ]
it's like
yeah people aren't trying to you can't
cancel him for anything like no one's
trying to cancel him it was a bad
relationship because it's just like oh
he was kind of like a fuckboard during
the relationship that's it you cheated
on her no not even cheating on her they
dated for like two months she came out
with a song they had a big age gap but
everything was legal and consensual and
if you were just like oh we've all been
there and dated like a shitty guy
so now we're gonna like take it out on
jake jones oh god damn yeah
that's rough imagine someone you dated
when you were
how old was he was you're like damn girl
we just didn't work 10 years ago a girl
that you dated 10 years old comes out
yeah and releases a 10 minute song about
you that blows the [ __ ] up and i read
death threats
from 16 year olds and like 30 year old
women what that's insane isn't it
that's funny death threats from 16 year
old
little girls just like that's the crazy
thing like some of these death threats
hey [ __ ] i'll tell your mom
you better stop [ __ ] with me i'll
call your [ __ ] parents
you're gonna be on punishment huh
i'm gonna get you grounded all right
we'll get you grounded [ __ ]
say bye-bye to homecoming yeah right
yeah
you ain't going from no more
it's kind of funny i mean that is
intense i mean yeah i mean just but
that's how she thrives huh
uh yeah i feel like to be fair yeah to
be fair there are just certain fan bases
you do not [ __ ] with
no no i'm saying that
she thrives off her relationship drama
um is that fair to say
i think it's more so her music but the
drama definitely does help sales it
definitely does i'm not even saying he's
like sales as much as like
helps her create
uh yes absolutely because all of that
comes from her record sales or anything
like that i'm just talking about like
because i mean i feel like she's someone
that has her fan base and they'll be
with her for the rest of her [ __ ]
yeah career yeah as long as she wants to
[ __ ] do music or even after that
it's like it's like dolly parton dolly
parton's had fans
for [ __ ] ever and she collects you
know new fans all the time yeah i'm
saying like you know like
as far as her creativity
absolutely that's where a bulk of her
material comes from is her past
relationships damn i should do that huh
yeah what am i doing yeah what are you
not doing that no
you gotta do that
do that
i would do that you gotta follow suit
i'm starting i'm starting to [ __ ]
trend there's gonna be taylor swift
olivia rodrigo chappelle lacy that's
that's olivia's olivio
uh olivia sorry olivia olivia there's 13
breakup socks huh it was 13 breakups
olivia rodriguez
it was all yeah look at you nick yeah i
love olivia rodriguez
wait are you a fan because i wanted to
go to her concert so badly i couldn't
get tickets because uh ticketmaster had
like had some sort of malfunction i
couldn't get a hold of tickets i was
gonna force coming here yes i was gonna
force stevie to go with me because i had
no friends like including my girlfriends
would not go to olivia rodriguez concert
and then i found out casey is a olivia
rodrigo fan i'm not finding out you're
olivia rodriguez
yeah i feel like i would have gone and
fought for these tickets if i knew i had
other people in my corner to go see
olivia rodrigo uh chen
i don't know who she is but she's great
that's cool love her songbird of this
upcoming generation she she's so
influential the white house hired her to
uh get vaccinated
did they really who is she
i'm still going to the concert uh she's
like 19. no uh
very pretty i recognize her face oh
she's super pretty yeah
but she really popped off during the
pandemic
yeah she's she is also 19 correct yeah
not that anybody said anything she just
turned 19. no no it's good to know yeah
no it was clarified or verified and we
need to know because we're not creeps
yeah we're not that's why that's why uh
adele is the same way too yeah bruno
mars ed sheeran's the same way
bruno mars only makes songs based off of
his uh for a while i feel like now with
his silk sonic stuff it's not so
like related i thought he made like dope
songs like hey i want to make love yeah
but like uh
you know what i mean i thought he was
doing that that's all that's what i feel
like all the songs are about
uh it's they're definitely all like love
songs i don't think they quite make that
face but something within that ballpark
you're close you're not quite there yet
you have more of an anderson pack face
right now i was thinking frank ocean
what the [ __ ] what's happening
all right i got a [ __ ] show tonight i
got to get ready for her
what time is it
uh time to go time for this to go all
right uh shout out to sponsors shout out
to the sponsors shout out to magic mind
shout out to [ __ ] uh stove shelf
stove shelf magnetic
magnetic
uh you got black and white you got
stainless steel and you got [ __ ]
heart
oh yeah
[Laughter]
he's in wisconsin we'll get you
yes so
wait is the title of this episode gonna
be stove show
every time it's a sponsor i did already
have that in the holster hell yeah
all right guys uh
oh yeah i got tour dates i'll be in uh
this already be out but i'll be
[Music]
uh so you already have done kansas then
so i'll be march 10th through the
let's just say christian
march 10th through the 12th i'll be in
springfield missouri at the blue room
comedy club april 8th and april 9th i'll
be in salt lake city at wiseguys comedy
club and then uh doing a one-nighter in
my hometown uh phoenix arizona at
stand-up live uh buy tickets to my shows
you know because uh you know what it's
hard selling [ __ ] tickets
and i don't know it's like you [ __ ]
you can
say it as much as you want push it out
there as much as you want and these
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
hey hey
listen when i say these [ __ ] dates
and also support my podcast repels world
boom
uh yeah catch me and my feet on
onlyfans.com
yeah yeah that's what that feet
see that's why i don't have a p.o box
that's what i imagined
that's what i imagined that's what every
guy looks like when they look at your
feet
[Laughter]
i
i've made a gift but i actually would
have to youtube it uh i don't know it's
they're not hard but
jen's vlogs
just uh thank you guys for watching we
were like kind of blown away seriously
how many people were watching and oh
yeah people are listening so thank you
guys and it's the per it's the it's the
arc i've seen all the time when shows
start like first episode there's
curiosity numbers are huge there's a
drop-off in the second episode but then
you start that becomes your baseline and
then you go up from there yeah and uh
that's how it's straight the best
supporters yeah it's dope it's been very
positive
um look out for that corey feldman video
coming soon it's gonna be
another podcast network uh
channel
and i'm super stoked about it
boom looks fun and then catch meatball
getting his ass beat by me and catch me
throwing up in the bathroom after this
episode uh or on instagram see parallel
six hey yo get him to ten thousand
followers i'm gonna say that every time
where are you at now uh 81.50 i think
come on guys how many did you get
like i get like 20 an episode i think
like 20. that's right oh you have some
[ __ ] he's got a fun follow-up he's
got a fun instagram uh it's just him
with a bunch of famous people
[Laughter]
uh brian
anything plug
just look after that finding corey short
doc yeah finding corey
oh you found him
a spoiler this one
[Laughter]
all right bye see ya bye
[Music]
you